the Vigilante wraith is coming to
Spider-Man 2 so here's her backstory
before you play for eight years Peter
has worked side by side with New York
police captain Yuri watab Yuri always
did things by the book a decision that
cost many lives watab targets the Maia
families who are the mafia of this
universe and in particular Don
Hammerhead but repeatedly finds every
time she makes an arrest the magia find
loopholes to leave jail freely this all
comes to a head when hammerhead takes
down an entire Task Force Under Yuri's
lead and after a long story wab takes
her revenge Yuri Hammerhead is okay by
the way that's a story for another time
watab is immediately removed from police
duty yet continues to work cases this
time she does not do everything by the
book If the evidence lines up she is now
judge jury and executioner Yuri watab
has gone Rogue how will her story end in
Spider-Man 2